oh
bonjour chers internautes on se retrouve
aujourd'hui pour diagonale la leçon avec
notre ami le maître international
jean-luc chavanon bonjour jean luc
bonjour bertrand alors on est heureux de
retrouver en même temps on est heureux
de vous dire qu'il a bien réussir une
norme de grands maîtres dans un tournoi
fermé ce qui prouve que l'on peut
travailler sur diagonale et continuer à
être efficace dans les tournois
alors aujourd'hui on a choisi une partie
d'un grand maître du passé d'un grand
champion du monde a les quines et on l'a
choisi parce que c'était une partie
quand on dirait une partie thématique
alors est ce que c'est important
jean-luc de regarder genre de partie
d'analysé genre de partie ben je pense
que c'est quelque chose de fondamental
donc dans cette partie donc daily qin
on apprend des choses essentielles donc
qui sont traîtres qui sont des éléments
stratégiques fondamentaux est très
important pour pour la compréhension du
jeu d'échecs bon ben alors je crois
qu'on peut y aller alors allons-y allons
zagat tente donc d4 donc avec qui on
commence par le pion de la dame dont
calais qui n'allait blanc oui donc à
l'équipe qui allait blanc évidemment
donc des quatre cavaliers f6 ces quatre
et six cavaliers f3 des cinq donc les
joueurs commencent par une position que
l'on appelle un gambit d'argovie dame
donc qui après quelques coups là donc
après cavaliers ces trois fosses est fou
fou g5 et refuser les deux c'est à dire
que les noirs ne veulent pas prendre le
pion en c4 il décide de se développer le
plus tôt possible
donc pour l'instant les éléments
essentiels du jeu d'échecs sont
respectés c'est à dire le développement
et le centre et le centre le
développement le centre c'est vraiment
les choses importantes pour le début de
partie
j-3 quiz ce sont des choses importantes
pour le début de partie c'est des choses
que l'on retrouve donc à chaque leçon
donc les choses fondamentales et la la
la les coups qui ont été jouées c'est
pratiquement le candidat me refuser ces
ou encore joué aujourd'hui c'est une des
variante on appelle ça une variante les
plus solides exactement ses larmes de
kasparov de karpov de krainik c'est
disons que c'est le type de position que
ses joueurs utilisent le lorsqu'ils
n'ont pas envie de perdre lorsqu'ils
veulent tenir la place alors ce qu'ils
ont envie de faire match nul
l'armature donc il joue une position
extrêmement solide et ils laissent à
leurs adversaires un chance à nombre de
chances à fismes pour pour obtenir une
victoire donc c'est faut bien regarder
ses coureurs gagnent en valeur en
continu donc petit rock donc les noirs
se développent de trois cavaliers b17
d'accord et l'a donc tour c'est un donc
tour c'est un le premier coup de dé
veloppement un petit peu curieux mais
très très important puisque la colonne c
est une colonne qui sur laquelle la tour
peut exercer une certaine pression donc
elle va pouvoir s'ouvrir pendant que le
couac chose qui fasse de toute façon
elle s'ouvrira soit les blés noirs
pendant ces 4 elle s'ouvrira soit les
blancs prendront en des 5 1 et donc elle
s'ouvrira donc c'est un coup est-il
exactement donc en plus dans cette
position les noirs qui sinon ne sont pas
complètement développé puisque leur fils
éviter le retour à 8 ne sont pas encore
là donc nous
ne peuvent pas vouloir vraiment de poser
de problèmes sérieux au roi rose centre
donc mais bon disons que le roi va quand
même devoir brooke est assez rapidement
donc ces six dames ces deux donc
toujours un développement ces six pour
consolider le centre dame ces deux pour
contrôler la case e cat d'accord donc
tours 8
et maintenant donc aller keane décide
donc évidemment de sortir son fou la
dernière pièce qui n'est pas développé
donc toujours un choix extrêmement
classique toujours en vue de contrôler
la case e4 et de faire petit rock donc
d'une manière générale dans cette
position je pense qu'on va on va quand
même voir que les blancs ont installé
quand même un duo de pions au centre
donc avec les pions avec les pions dans
cette position avec le pion aux c4 et le
pian des 4 alors que les noirs donc le
pion en dessin donc pour l'instant il y
à il y à une supériorité donc au centre
chez les blancs qui contrôle très très
bien les les cases centrale donc voilà
ce qui c'est ce qu'on essaye de faire
toujours un ca bons conseils que vous
pouvez donner c'est à dire de contrôle
et d'essayer de mettre deux pions au
centre auprès du centre pour essayer de
contrôler les quatre centrales ça c'est
important
ah oui est-ce que vous avez vous surtout
dans ce type de position parce que ce
qu'il faut dire c'est que dans cette
position donc où les blancs commencent
par par des deux des cats donc dans
cette position les blancs n'ont pas la
possibilité donc de développer leurs
pièces rapidement donc se situe à un
type de position qu'on appelle des
positions fermes et donc contrairement à
eux deux quatre ou les positions sont
ouvertes et où les pièces se développe
rapidement et on peut éventuellement
comme on l'a vu à plusieurs reprises
développer des attaques des attaques
fulgurantes ou développer des stratégies
extrêmement plus agressif dans ce type
de position en a on obtient ce que l'on
appelle plutôt le jeu positionnelle donc
il faut s'installer sur les sur les
points stratégiques vitaux de la
position si donc le centre et plus
particulièrement le centre donc et
l'espace le jeu positionne l1 c'est les
points c'est quand m contrôler les
points stratégiques exactement là on va
voir dans cette partie comment les kids
l'a fait parce qu'elle est vraiment
modèle cette partie exactement
donc food et 3d prend sekkat donc dans
cette position les noirs décide donc
d'abandonner donc provisoirement donc le
centre en provisoire le mans
provisoirement est important le mot
provisoirement est important parce que
quand on joue des procès cat aux échecs
quand on les change ce pion donc là on
laisse aux blancs la possibilité donc
d'installer d'installer ce duo de pions
c'est à dire le pion
le plan des cats et le pion aux trois
donc de les installer éventuellement le
cadre de faire un petit peu ce qu'ils
veulent au centre les pions en face on a
les pions sait si c'est aussi ce qu'ils
sont il faut le dire en attente d'une
libération
parce que dans cette position cissé puis
on reste sur ces cases on peut dire que
le food et java va être complètement
mort il va être derrière tout tous et
tous ces duos de pions et les pièces
noires vont avoir un de gros problèmes
pour se mobiliser pour essayer d'obtenir
une certaine activité
c'est à dire la torah 8 et la
communication des tours et tous ces
petits problèmes
pour résumer quand on n'a pas le centre
ce qu'elle cas des noirs ici c'est qu'on
a un peu moins d'espacé donc on a un peu
moins d'air pour ses pièces et ça
exactement exactement donc voilà donc
dans cette position après faut penser 4
les noirs en profite donc pour jouer
donc donc dans cette position pour jouer
pour jouer donc cavalier dessin tu as à
l'idée de secousses et d'échangés un peu
de pièces pour ce fonds se donner de
l'air c'est ça exactement donc c'est que
finalement donc peut-être que s'il est
fou c'est change donc la dame va
reprendre et on aura peut-être plus de
facilités pour jouer le coup libérateur
donc le 6e 5 donc qui pourrait être
éventuellement un coup libérateur et qui
permettrait aux fous de se développer et
au centre d'être quelque peu comment
dire neutraliser un peu détruit
d'échanger quelques purs au centre donc
on peut dire que d'une manière générale
après cavaliers des singles et noir
tentent de se libérer donc là dans cette
position refus refus de l'échangé direct
chez les blancs par cavalier c'est 3e
cat donc là c'est une manoeuvre qui est
un petit peu tactique et un petit peu
positionnelle dans sa peau je crois que
là les kin veut poser une sorte de piège
stratégique c'est ça oui allez king
commence à préparer à préparer donc
quelques pièges de stratégie donc le
cavalier très très bien placé au centre
donc on le cavalier donc au centre qui a
des vues donc sur ces cases assez faible
donc on va prendre la case des six la
case c5 donc le cavalier qui contrôle
très très bien ces cases éventuellement
le cavalier donc peut revenir sur la
case d3 et permet de la poussée du pion
en de cannes est aussi donc le cavalier
qui a plusieurs fonctions qui peut aussi
donc après les changes du des fous donc
en général on prendra plutôt avec ce
cavalier mémé joué un rôle très
important pour l'attack du pion h c'est
une attaque directe et eva seulement
donc trouver quelques compensations
tactique dans cette position non plein
plein de plus servi de test le faux
geste évidemment le cavalier protège
très très important il faut défendre ses
pièces donc le cavalier défend le fou g5
qui était attaqué donc deux fois par le
fouet la dap donc voilà la possibilité
de prendre ce fou donc voilà le le rôle
de ce cavalier au centre en plus comme
les pièces blanches sens mieux organisés
il n'est pas nécessaire d'échanger ses
pièces c'est une chose importante je
pense que lorsqu'une pièce est bien
placé et qu'en face l'adversaire propose
d'échanger une pièce qui est mal placée
ou qui gêne les pièces adverse
il vaut mieux ne pas les changer donc là
c'est la règle que vous que vous donner
c'est à dire quand il ya propositions
des changements regarde quelle est la
meilleure pièce des deux exactement
exactement par exemple là pour expliquer
un petit peu plus clairement
donc on va revenir à cette position je
vais enlever un petit peu toutes ces
étoiles donc un coût plutôt donc dans
cette position ce que je vous dis ce que
je voudrais donc expliquer c'est que
dans cette position lorsque le lorsque
le cavalier donc je viens sur quatre
dans cette position si on échange les
cavaliers en d5 par exemple donc dans
cette position après cavaliers prend des
on va imaginer par exemple e6 prend des
cinq les fous qui sont alors emprise
doivent s'échanger donc on doit prendre
le fond le 7 et bouger le fou après quoi
les noirs vont jouer cavalier 17 et 6
on arrête la variante ici le bilan c'est
que les noirs sont quasiment développer
contrôle bien le centre et les blancs
n'ont tiré aucun avantage de leur
position on peut dire qu'ils ont fait
des fautes fondamentale des fautes assez
bête alors que en jouant cavalier e 4
donc en jouant le coup qui a été jouée
par aline lecavalier donc contrôler des
cases stratégiques importantes et les
noirs pour l'instant on toujours donc ce
duo de pions plus disons plutôt passive
par rapport à ce duo de pions moins
dynamique ne peuvent pas se libérer sur
eux 5 parce que le cavalier et le plan
des cas de contrôle est actuellement ne
peuvent pas se libérer sur ces 5 parce
que le pion lecavalier et éventuellement
ses pièces sur la colline ces contrôles
donc les noirs ne peuvent pas se libérer
au centre de cette position en plus on
peut dire que
que ce cavalier en dessin à n'importe
quel moment peut être attaqué par le
pion à eux revenir sur des cases et donc
manqué un petit peu de cases qu'on dira
de cases clé où ils pourraient contrôler
très très bien la position
donc là on va on va continuer mais dans
cette position on peut dire que le blond
sont un petit avantage ouverture des
ancêtres cette position donc chez les
experts donc est une position géré
avantages et coordonne la légère
avantage blanc sans problème donc f5
alors f5 ça il faut que tu commandes
voilà donc ça c'est un coup impulsif
c'est un coup impulsif donc f5
un coût qui est à la base qui est
destiné donc au contrôle donc de la case
centrale de 4 mais malheureusement un
cookie qui kick ass qui ne respectent
pas les règles fondamentales donc c'est
à dire le développement les noirs ne
développe pas leur pièce est également
dans cette position les noirs
affaiblissent leur structure
mais comment dire de manière importante
c'est à dire le pion le pion aux six se
retrouvent extrêmement faibles donc f5 à
un coût qui si les noirs sont
extrêmement bien développé peut être
justifiée mais qui dans ce cas là où les
noirs n'ont rien développé du tout et en
asie et un affaiblissement est la pure
et simple
hélas ce qui est génial parce qu'on nous
on connaît un peu la partie s'est calé
keane va pratiquement ne jouer que sur
les faiblesses occasionnés par ce coup
oui dans cette position donc ali qui
donc va tout simplement essayer
finalement de de simplifier la position
puisque actuellement les noirs on crée
donc des faiblesses et cbs chronique
donc des faiblesses chroniques dans leur
position et alors on il faut voir que en
mettant un pion sur la couleur du fou
car sa première provient donc le mauvais
fou comment la règle pour savoir si on a
un bon ou un mauvais flou voilà une des
règles essentielles donc si le voir dans
un premier temps le nombre de pions qui
sont sur les cases du fou donc là comme
le pion au f5 et le pian 2 600 sur la
case du faux on peut considérer qu'il
est mauvais et dans un deuxième temps
aussi regarder le nombre de cases sur
lesquels le fou peut jouer alors là dans
cette position je pense que quand le
fonds peut jouer sur la case 17
uniquement on peut dire que c'est pas un
frein pour l'instant n'est pas
extraordinaire
donc ça c'est les 2 c les deux choses
essentielles premier problème de ce coup
c'est que ça fait sacré un fou pas
fantastique
oui on va dire qu'on va dire ce
comment dans cette place que dans
finances dans cette position un joueur
débutant pour être embêté parce qu'il
dit les noirs viennent d'attaquer mon
cavalier si j'enlève mon cavalier
n'importe où mais je vais perdre une
pièce donc c'est ça aussi qu'il faut si
on veut progresser au début on est un
peu embêté par la tactique même s'il ne
faut pas calculer beaucoup donc là
comment comment aller keane va résoudre
ce petit problème est finalement prendre
un avantage stratégique déterminant dans
la fois que tu expliques parce que vous
êtes vous êtes bientôt grand maître pour
vous c'est évident pour le joueur même
moyens sont des concepts qui sont pas
forcément évident donc là je pense qu'il
faut vraiment bien l'expliquer donc on
va prendre la première étape donc la
première étape de ce café à les kin dans
cette position donc on va voir donc il
est noir attaque le cavalier dans un
premier temps mais il faut regarder la
position s'est dit il faut regarder les
nombre de pièces emprise donc dans cette
position de lecavalier est en prise mais
le fouet cette emprise
donc si on bouge lecavalier il faut voir
que le fougueux 7 peut prendre le fond j
auquel cas le cavalier reprendre à
angers sac donc on va juste mettre
quelques petites flèches donc sur
cavaliers revient sur cette case en d2
par exemple ce serait une faute très
grave
terrible parce que le fou peut prendre
le fond g5 donc aux échecs très
important de calculer un petit peu et de
compter le matériel de faire très
attention matériel parce qu'après tout
projet sact lecavalier prend le fond g5
mais la dame donc il ne faut pas oublier
la dernière pièce va re reprendre le
fond gesac donc là et les calculs et de
coupe il faut calculer de coûts d'un
coup deux coups et après ces deux coups
donc la pièce était été perdu donc ça
tombe bien puisque dans cette
position-là solutions dans cette
position
c'est d'échanger les fous alors c'est
une solution à la fois tactique pour
éviter donc tout simplement de perdre la
pièce donc on commence par un coin parce
qu'on appelle un coup intermédiaire donc
dans cette position on joue fou prend le
cet accord pour ne pas perdre deux
pièces exactement donc on ne peut pas
prendre le cavalier en cat
parce que le fougueux cette attaque la
dame en des huit évidemment donc on
commence par ce qu'on appelle un coup
intermédiaire mais en même temps c'est
un coup stratégique très très très
puissant puisque depuis depuis tout à
l'heure on a compris que le fond ces
huit étaient mauvais donc pourquoi ne
pas échanger le foot cases noires comme
ça on comme le furent dans le nez sio2
de laisser les noirs avec une mauvaise
pioche on va laisser les noirs avec une
pièce qui est enfermée derrière les les
cases des cases blanches et en même
temps on va obtenir avec les cavaliers
qui pourront éventuellement se recycler
sur la case des deux baies 3 et revenir
sur ces 5 où le cavalier qui va pouvoir
se jeter sur re5 avoir un contrôle
absolu des cases noires donc on va
vraiment laissé les les noirs dans dans
des difficultés insurmontables
donc après fou pour cette dame prendre
sept cavaliers des deux donc cavalier d2
donc on recycle le cavalier qui était en
prise et éventuellement on s'apprête à
rebondir donc sur les cases noires un
peu plus tard
de toute façon pour l'instant dans ce
cas vous session six cavaliers des deux
c'est pas on aurait pu jouer qu'avec les
g3 on aurait pu jouer cavalier c3
pourquoi cavaliers des deux donc
cavalier d2 c'est disons que ça et c'est
un coup est ce qu aux échecs de reculer
c'est un mauvais coup visiblement pas
c'est l'échec ce n'est pas forcément un
mauvais coup aux échecs il ya ce qu'on
appelle des manoeuvres les manoeuvres
les manoeuvres positionnelle par exemple
sont des manoeuvres qui permettent
d'amener donc une case sur une pièce sur
la meilleure case possible par exemple
donc les manoeuvres de pièces donc dans
ce cas on peut dire que comme je
l'expliquais lecavalier en revenant donc
sur la case des deux donc va pouvoir
éventuellement rebondir donc si ce
cavalier 20 sur cinq va pouvoir rebondir
sur
sur la case f3 d'accord et
éventuellement rebondir sur la case d3
et de ses cases il aura la possibilité
d'aller sur les cases noires dans le
camp noir et obtenir des avants postes
extrêmement de extrêmement puissant qui
vont handicaper les noirs à un maximum
donc les noirs qui ne sont toujours pas
développé d'ailleurs les actions pour la
leur alors que si lecavalier bien sûr
j'ai 3 il a la possibilité de venir sur
eux deux qui n'est pas vraiment une
cadre extraordinaire et il ne peut plus
revenir sur la case
la case 4 la possibilité d'aller sur la
case h5 qui est une case excentré aussi
important donc le cavalier qui quand
même dans toutes ces manoeuvres vient
sur des cases qui lui permettent de
contrôler quand même le plus de casse
possible à savoir qu'un cavalier donc un
cavalier lorsqu'il est située sur la
bande de l'échiquier contrôle beaucoup
moins de gaz que lorsqu'il est situé sur
une case centrale
enfin s'il faut le redire toujours c'est
des choses très très importante c'est à
dire que donc aux échecs les pièces
doivent doivent être sur des cases où
elles sont extrêmement puissante et est
active
voilà donc ça c'est des choses
importantes donc là encore une une
grosse faute donc
yat donc bon on va dire une grosse faute
mais bon dans cette partie était jouée à
l'époque où toutes les toutes les bases
tous les fondements du jeu d'échecs ont
été inventés donc les noirs dans cette
position
joue b5 les noirs jouent b5 dans un
souci finalement de 2 pouces et un petit
peu ces pièces il crée une menace
directe en attaquant le fou et encore
une fois on va comprendre qu'aux échecs
donc les menaces directes ne sont pas
les menaces
forcément les plus les plus elles sont
évidemment nécessaires toujours quelques
fois ci un petit peu son adversaire en
lui en lui en lui faisant des petits des
petites menaces mais ce sont plus
particulièrement des habitudes de petits
joueurs qu'il faut faire attention à ses
équipes et en quoi qu'ils sont un petit
peu malin 10 ans qui tente en essayent
d'attaquer un fou ou attaquer une pièce
mais il faut aux échecs surtout joué
très très stratégique et donc dans cette
position donc en attaquant le fou
évidemment on menace le fou mais ce
qu'il faut voir c'est qu'on met encore
un peu plus sur la couleur du sur la
couleur du fou c'est 8
on ne développe toujours pas les pièces
donc la punition la punition approche
dans cette position et en plus on ait
faibli en effet publie donc quelque
chose de très important c'est dans cette
position
les noirs affaiblissent donc la fameuse
colonne c deuxième avantage
voilà donc là maintenant après avoir
obtenu donc le contrôle des cases noires
l'enfermement du fou le meilleur
développement on obtient la colonne c
voilà donc on va les aider
on peut dire ce sont des éléments très
importants et on peut aussi dire que
c'est un joueur qui en treize coups
obtient autant davantage ne peut être
que champion du monde mais donc c'est à
dire que il ya une différence de niveau
entre les deux joueurs qui est très
importante ce qui rend d'ailleurs la
partie est d'autant plus instructives
puisqu'on va voir l'exploitation donc de
tout
toutes ses forces dans la position donc
après cette descente donc fou prend des
voilà donc aller qu'il n'a pas peur donc
de donner son fou contre le cavalier
parce qu' évidemment dans cette position
les cavaliers donc les cavaliers f3 et
cavaliers des deux sont les maîtres du
jeu qui sont les maîtres absolus
ils ont un contrôle de toutes les cases
noires ils peuvent s'installer où ils
veulent et le fou en face est
complètement
complètement out si on peut le dire donc
fou pour des 5 alors là donc dans cette
position il faut reprendre le fonds des
cinq et il faut le reprendre avec le
pion ses 6 mai ont permis sinon
interactions donc s'éprend des cinq donc
un petit bilan dans cette position donc
la colonne c'est comme je l ai dit tout
à l'heure à partir au blanc connaissait
les quatre centrales appartiennent les
quatre centrales noir appartiennent aux
blancs les blancs sont mieux développer
le foot 15 noir est enfermé ans et 8
donc tout ça tout ça maintenant
maintenant si on va voir comment les kin
voilà alors et démonstrations exactement
donc les blancs ne cherche pas à
solutionner donc tous ces problèmes
immédiatement on n'oublie pas les bons
coups le rock exact vous permet de
mettre la dernière pièce un jeu hexa
core a dit le rock c'est quand même
souvent très souvent un bon coup
exactement
en plus ça permet quoi ça permet au tour
d'autres coordonnées donc éventuellement
cette tour f1 pourra venir un peu plus
tard sur la colonne 6 si besoin est pour
pour encore plus dominé donc cette
colonne donc petit run à 5 à 5 on va
dire que là c'est le premier cookies qui
est justifiée dans cette position chez
les noirs c'est le première la première
chose à peu près correct c'est à dire
que les noirs cherche on va dire une
sortie pour le fou c'est 8
mais évidemment sans développement sans
sans aucune aucune force stratégique
autour on peut dire que c'est quand même
quelque chose d'un peu dérisoire si on
peut dire que c'est encore encore une
vision assez optimiste d'une
une position qui ne l'est pas du tout
cas qui n'est pas du tout excellente à
cinq cavaliers b3 donc comme ce que l'on
a expliqué tout à l'heure la halle et
les blancs s'installe d'ailleurs ils
doivent s'installer immédiatement parce
que si les blancs n'avaient pas joué
cavalier b3 les noirs auraient pu jouer
donc à 4 et empêcher le cavalier donc
devenir sur la case c5 donc dans cette
position les blancs donc les noirs
jouent à cat et moi c'est comme ça que
tu dis ça simplement parce que aux
échecs il faut jouer le temps l'espace
et le temps aussi siècle on peut pas
faire c'est quand même ce qu'on veut
exempter keane exactement même à
l'équipe dans cette position il ne peut
pas se permettre d'attendre parce que
s'il attend quelques coups bon dans
quelques cool si les noirs arrivent à
achever leur développement en sortant
leurs fous ces 8es en occupant la
colonne c'est la position peut être
complètement neutralisé donc voilà il
faut bien gérer la notion de
développement et et voilà donc cavalier
b 3 à 4 qui avalise c'est simple non
plus cavalier s'installe donc cavalier
français cinq dames français 5 donc l'
occupation totale de l'anah le passeur
d'échanger les dames quand on
al'avantage leur nom lorsque les pieds
lorsque l'on regarde les bonnes pièces
non non toujours une fois de chaque
échange de pièces dépendent de la sève
de la fonction de chaque de la pièce
qu'ils en échange si la pièce a un rôle
très utile et que c'est la meilleure et
que la solution est de la garde et il
faut la garder
là les dames sont toutes les deux
actives on peut les échanger sur toutes
les deux tours vont pouvoir rentrer sur
la colonne s'est donc bekkat tour est
d'accord c'est un doublé sur la colonne
maintenant les avantages stratégiques en
l'air au lycée las cases centre à 2,5
complètement aux mains des blancs et
l'absolue c est la colonne c est la
commune c est toujours davantage de
développement donc fois six cavaliers ou
cinq on s'installe surtout ca c'est ce
qu'on appelle une casse forte
exactement et éventuellement plus tard
occupation de la septième dans cette
position à la rai à tout outil hier on
va y arriver donc tourné huit tours b 8
pour éventuellement le maître la tour
sur bessette et défendre le tueur bcap
qui pourrait être éventuellement
attaquer donc toujours encore comme
quelques règles oppositionnel donc f3 un
coût très important évidemment un coût
très important puisqu'il prépare dans
la sortie la sortie du king c'est à dire
que le roi est aussi une pièce
exactement le roi est une pièce
fondamentale et le roi donc dans cette
position le roi va éventuellement venir
sur ici sur f2 sur g3 sur f 4 en finale
en fin de partie le roi peut monter au
centre sebbar ampleur pénale en début de
partie on met le roi le cash dans le
petit côté on le cache derrière le rock
où il y a le plus de points possibles
est en finale on n'hésite pas à le
monter au centre puisque évidemment le
milieu de partie est un moment de la
partie où l'on peut mater le roi et la
finale par définition est un moment de
partie où le roi ne peut qu
exceptionnellement être mat et donc le
roi est une pièce comme une autre qui a
un rôle qui a un rôle donc qui peut doit
rentrer donc dans le dans l'action donc
f3b 3 donc dans cette position b3 donc
les noirs décide de pousser leurs pions
à 3h 6 wild donc le roi commence à
monter alors qu'en face le roi le roi g8
lui ne peut pas vraiment monté très très
loin puisque le cavalier donc le
cavalier en cinq contrôles les cases fct
g6 contrôler ces deux cases et donc
domine un petit peu le roi g8
donc on va voir un petit peu ce qui se
passe droit dans cette position donc 3 h
7 h 4 donc toujours un coût pour éviter
les pour éviter la poussée du pion du
plan du pion et là on enlève vraiment
toutes les possibilités que si
éventuellement la possibilité dû plonger
plus tard pour contrôler un peu plus de
un peu plus de deux cases donc tous
réfutent les noirs dans cette position
sont complètement ils sont complètement
soumis soumis donc aux blancs sont tous
rêvent des huit tours c'est cette la
tour sur la 7e donc on ne cesse de
rappeler que la septième rangée est un
des points stratégiques aux échecs donc
la septième rangée donc
important très important donc dans cette
position on essaie d dominer une colonne
pour rentrer un septième exactement
aujourd'hui on est vraiment à l'école
l'école des échecs à exactement on
apprend tout ce qu'il faut pour bien
jouer donc tour c'est cette fougue et
cinq wilayas plus grand chose à faire
pour ces 5 x 6 tours ces six tours tours
1,8 pour défendre le pion au 6 qui a
taclé au f4 leroy améliore sa position
roy g8 h5 donc la domination totale donc
là c'est c'est un massacre
simplement j'ai trois le pion a été
attaquée fois ci ce donc le fou qui ne
peut attaquer quasiment aucun pion de
haut qu'un pion chez les noirs donc tous
rêvent 7
ça y est maintenant on va devoir doubler
en septième les noirs près par le
doublement des tours sur la septième
rangée rouages cette tour c'est cette
les tours sont doublés et attaque le
plan g7
il faut défendre le plan g7 est là dans
cette position on va terminer par une
petite une petite combinaison alpes la
petite combinaison c'était la spécialité
d'un ogre en championnat contemporain
daily qin son grand opposant c'est est
capable en cas alors c'est quoi cette
petite combinaison quand on a dominé la
position comme ça donc il ya un sens
stratégique
oui donc encore une fois c'est optimiser
son jeu de pièces est dans cette
position exploitée donc un petit
exercice de style permettre donc l'exclu
l'exploitation donc de petit élément
stratégique c'est-à-dire la domination
finalement du roi qui est dans une sorte
de réseau c'est à dire le roi ne peut
pas sortir de son rock
il n'a plus qu'une seule case donc la
petite combinaison cavaliers 17 un
cavalier 17 qui dans cette peña dans
cette position menace donc le cavalier
menace de venir sur la case m6 où il
attaque le roi en h7 est là tout ranger
8 et le pion g7 ne peut pas prendre le
cavalier parce qu'il est cloué donc on
va voir un petit peu ce qui s'est passé
après cavaliers 17
donc après cavaliers 17 donc dans cette
position
cavalier 17 3 h huit cavaliers 6 tout de
même
oui alors là surplus on prend cavaliers
tour h cet échec et mat c'est la force
des septièmes de la septième rangée
exactement lui donc touré fuite la tour
doit bouger puisque on attaque la tour
voilà et après tout réfute tout reprend
j'essaie alors là oui là c'est assez
rigolo donne une pièce alors on va
essayer de comprendre pourquoi et la
combinaison qui vraiment
encore est donc cet exercice de style et
elle était destinée donc à attaquer
cette tour par russell donc une
combinaison qui fait utiliser toutes les
pièces de l'échiquier
c'est à dire le roi le cavalier qui
vient de disparaître et les deux tours
donc le roi attaque la tour la tour peut
être défendu par le tour en effet fuite
donc voilà donc surtout reif 8
malheureusement lorsque la tour vian et
fuites la tour j'ai cette attaque leroy
nash cet échec leur revient en g8
hélas la tour 7 vient angers cet échec
et mat
donc la tour arrive six et dominer la
tour ne peut pas redescendre en réfute
on va prendre la tour et on va se
retrouver avec une position complètement
gagnante est un battant quelques coups
grâce aux deux tours sur la septième
alors un bilan en trois phrases de cette
partie ou de ce genre de partie donc
dans cette partie on a on a appris donc
les les éléments essentiels c'est à dire
le développement comme d'habitude peut
donc le jeu au sens insisté là dessus
exactement le jeu au centre le contrôle
des 15 faible et donc on a aussi appris
donc la valeur du du mauvais fou des
éléments stratégiques positionnelle
différents très bien merci
jean luc et puis à bientôt pour une
autre grande partie voilà